في ليبيا اشعلت الزياره المرتقبه لرئيسه
الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا ميلوني الى
طرابلس ازمه جديده بين الافريقاء فحكومه
باشاغا نددت بما وصفته بانتهازيه روما
وحذرت من تاثيره هذه الزياره على علاقات
البلدينها على اعتبار انها ستزيد من مكاسب
عملاق الطاقه الايطاليه ايني على حساب
المصالح الليبيه اكثر من ذلك شددت حكومه
بشار على انها لن تلتزم باي اتفاقيات
مشبوهات الغرض والماكولات واكدت انها
ستلجا للقضاء
على ارادات النفط لعام 22 22 والبالغه
اكثر من 130 مليار دينار ورغم حاله الغضب
من حكومه باشا ومعسكر الشرق الا انا
الاستعدادات للزياره قائمه وبقوه
وتفاصيلها مع منير الاشهب
تستعدوا طرابلسي لاستقبال وفد ايطاليه
رفيع المستوى مطلع الاسبوع القادم على
راسه رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه رفقه وزيري
الداخليه والخارجيه ومدير عام شركه
الايطاليه الذي سيقد اجتماعا مع رئيس
المؤسسه الوطنيه للنفط فرحات بنيدار مصادر
الليبيه تتحدث عن توقيع اتفاقيه النفطيه
مع شركه مما يعكس وتغيرا في ملفات السياسه
الليبيه الايطاليه
المنافس المباشر لاني في ليبيا خصوصا في
ظل الانقسام الاوروبي تجاهها الملف الليبي